[Applause]
[Music]
I was talking to my little grandson on
the phone he's saying grandpa please you
got to come and help with the fires at
the back door
[Applause]
[Music]
it really looks like something from
another world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
an extreme fire caused by extreme
conditions this is California and large
Suede's of America's golden state are
burning out of control but even for a
state that is hardened to the seasonal
hazard these fires are exceptionally
fierce it's one of the worst starts to
the fire season in a decade every single
person that I've talked to so far has
made the mention that I don't know why
it's doing what it's doing it's burning
differently it's burning
more aggressive than then it has in
years past and I know we say that every
year but it's it's unprecedented it's
burning in every direction all at the
same time fanned by dry winds spreading
fast through tinder like scrubland left
parched by five years of drought
[Music]
that's why this is now the seventh most
destructive blaze in state history
everything is against the thousands of
firefighters drafted into battle the
blaze
there is some help from the cloudless
skies firefighting aircraft have been
called in but there aren't enough
machines to cover the entire area
the fires have spread across 48,000
acres of land an area larger than the
city of San Francisco stifling heat
temperatures hovering around 38 degrees
Celsius and that's away from the fires
containment by lighting backfires works
sometimes
but when one blazes out another starts
the cycle is endless
it's exhausting
it's deadly Emily for her brother James
five and their great-grandmother melody
among the first victims I was only going
about 15 minutes when my wife called me
and said you got to get here the fire is
coming up the hill I was talking to my
little grandson on the phone he's saying
grandpa please you got to come in he'll
was the fires at the back door come and
get us I said I'm close my son I'm
trying to get in there I said I'm oh I'm
hold on and there will be more
heartbreak because many are still
missing the priority is to save life
emergency evacuation orders are in place
tens of thousands have been told to
leave we kind of gathered everything
that we could think of that we needed or
wanted in case and put it all in one
area so that if something like this
happened we could get as much of the
stuff that we can't replace out they
take what they can but have to leave
behind almost everything else but some
insist on staying despite the danger my
wife left I told them I ain't going I
I'm gonna say try to save my house
the ones who do leave know that they
will probably return to scenes like this
a scorched landscape the core
temperature can reach over 1,000 degrees
Celsius and the blaze is creating fire
whirls spinning vortexes of air ash and
fire they form when rising hot air
begins to spin collecting flammable
gases and burning debris the wind just
took off and I don't remember exactly
what they called it it was almost like a
tornado with fire in it and it came over
the hill and it wiped out our house it
wiped out our next-door neighbor's home
just all kinds of debris flying around
the air and hot embers and hot leaves
coming down all over the yard I figured
I better get out of here
these blazing tornadoes are particularly
dangerous and difficult to put out
meet dozens of meters in heights this
was like you see in the movies with
tornadoes I mean it it one minute it's
fine the next minute everybody's
screaming that's north
20:18 is set to be the 4th hottest year
on record only three other years have
been hotter 2015 16 and 17 the world is
undeniably heating up record
temperatures are being recorded across
North America and Asia and here in
Europe too long hot breezy dry spells
perfect for one of Greece's deadliest
ever wildfires
the seaside resort is popular with
Greeks and foreign tourists and was
completely unprepared the residence of
Marty stood little chance of escape the
coastal town east of Athens lacked good
evacuation access roads
there was no warning system in place
even though is a residential area
surrounded by forests and at high risk
of wildfires as the fire tore through
the town residents had a choice stay and
be burned alive or try and escape into
the sea hundreds did make it to the
water but hundreds didn't exact casualty
figures are hard to come by at least 91
people are known to have died many more
are in hospital some are in a very
serious condition and dozens are still
missing
recovering and identifying the Dead is
proving difficult sometimes impossible
because some of the bodies are so badly
burned that some body bags contain the
remains on more than one person
Kirika miracles
man or animal sadly are rare
this dog crawled into a brick built oven
behind a garden barbeque area it's white
fur now singed by the smoke and it was
barely able to breathe when it was found
by rescuers an investigation into the
response to the fire is underway it may
find more lives could have been saved by
planning for an eventuality like this
but not much else because the weather is
beyond the control of town officials
they there will be more common more
frequent extreme weather phenomena
because the climate globally is being
destabilized
[Music]
officials here in America and across the
world must now prepare and plan for this
nightmare
there have been wildfires in Britain
Sweden the Czech Republic and a deadly
heat wave in Japan this year alone with
global temperatures continuing to rise
year-on-year the warning from some
climate experts is that this is the
terrifying new normal